This tweet from Tepolyev
yesterday is blatantly unconstitutional
and it's worth talking about why?
It refers to a broken healthcare system,
a doctor shortage,
and that the problem is caused by some unnamed
gatekeepers.
Yet. But yeah, it is
implicitly saying that as Prime Minister of Canada,
he would act to remove those gatekeepers.
Accompanied by a short video
where he talks to a future medical student
about the problems the student might have
getting licensed to practice back in Canada
after having gotten his education somewhere else.
The problem here is
the Constitution of Canada
doesn't actually give the federal government
any powers over medical licensing.
Our constitution gives that exclusive jurisdiction
to the provinces.
By promising to use his hypothetical power
as Prime Minister to remove those gatekeepers,
Pierre Pualeev is promising federal overreach
into the exclusive powers of the provinces.
It's worth noting
nor in the tweet
or in the video does he give any concrete examples of
how he might remove those gatekeepers.
Probably cause he knows anything he proposes
is going to violate the spirit of the constitution.
Not picking specifically on Pippo
you have here,
because politicians of all major
Canadian federal parties do this all the time.
They do it because it's popular
and because they count on us
as electors
to not understand our own constitution.
We as electors
should not reward them for it.